THANK YOU VERY MUCH, EVERYBODY
WELCOME, WELCOME, WELCOME,
WELCOME TO "THE TONIGHT SHOW."
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
HAPPY FRIDAY
WELL GUYS, HERE IS SOME BIG
NEWS, EARLIER TODAY JOHNSON &
JOHNSON ANNOUNCED ITS
SINGLE-SHOT COVID VACCINE HAS
COMPLETED ITS GLOBAL TRIAL AND
WILL SOON BE AVAILABLE
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
YEP, JOHNSON & JOHNSON SAID
THEIR VACCINE WAS PROVEN TO BE
66% EFFECTIVE.
WAY TO GO?
66%?
PRETTY MUCH THE D STUDENT OF
THE VACCINE WORLD.
NOT FAILING, BUT WE WOULD
REALLY LIKE TO BUMP THAT
AVERAGE UP TO A C PLUS BY NEXT
SEMESTER
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON VACCINE
SHOWED UP LATE AND IT GOT
A 66%.
IT'S BASICALLY THE SPICOLI OF
VACCINES
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THE
RESULTS, KEEP IN MIND, HOT
POCKETS WERE JUST RECALLED FOR
BEING 66% GLASS AND AMERICANS
STILL ATE THEM
[ APPLAUSE ]
BUT THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON
VACCINE IS STILL CONSIDERED
EFFECTIVE AND IT DOES HAVE SOME
GOOD THINGS GOING FOR IT
LISTEN TO THIS
IT'S ONE SHOT, NOT TWO, AND IT
ALSO DOES NOT NEED TO BE KEPT
IN THOSE NEAR FREEZING
TEMPERATURES LIKE THE OTHER
TWO.
>> Jimmy: YEP, UNLIKE THOSE
PFIZER AND MODERNA VACCINES
YOU'VE GOT TO WINE AND DINE,
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON ONE WILL
HOOK UP WITH YOU IN A BACK
ALLEY.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
AND THIS SHOULDN'T BE
OVERLOOKED, THE JOHNSON &
JOHNSON VACCINE IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT PROMISES NO TEARS IF IT
GETS IN YOUR EYES.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
MEANWHILE, AS THE VIRUS
CONTINUES TO SURGE AND NEW
VARIANTS ARISE, EXPERTS ARE
ENCOURAGING DOUBLE MASKING FOR
INCREASED PROTECTION AGAINST
COVID.
NOT EXACTLY THE BIG MEDICAL
BREAKTHROUGH I WAS HOPING FOR.
11 MONTHS IN AND SOMEONE IS
LIKE, "UM, TWO MASKS
I'M GONNA GO TO LUNCH.
OH, AND IF YOU WEAR THOSE
FLIMSY BLUE ONES THAT COME IN
PACKS OF 50, THEY SUGGEST YOU
WEAR ALL 50.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
BUT DR. FAUCI SUPPORTS WEARING
TWO MASKS.
IN A BRIEF STATEMENT HE SAID -
[ INAUDIBLE
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE NOT ALL
WINNERS, FOLKS
YOU KNOW, YOU'VE GOT TO TRY
THEM -
[ LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE
AND BE HAPPY WITH WHAT YOU GET
YEAH, HEALTH EXPERTS ARE SAYING
THAT AS COVID KEEPS EVOLVING,
ONE OF THE BEST THINGS PEOPLE
CAN DO IS WEAR A DOUBLE FACE
MASK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO FOLLOW THESE
GUIDELINES, SO JUST TO GET
EVERYBODY ON BOARD -
♪
HEY, IT'S ALMOST FEBRUARY.
ALMOST VALENTINE'S DAY
SO IF YOU WANT TO SHOW THAT
SPECIAL SOMEONE YOU REALLY
CARE, ALL YOU GOTTA DO IS SLIDE
INTO THE DMs
THE DOUBLE MASKS
♪ YOU GOT TO SLID
INTO THE DMs
DMs MEANS SOMETHIN
DIFFERENT NOW ♪
♪ IT MEANS DOUBLE MASKS
YOU'VE GOT TO DOUBLE
THAT MASK ♪
>> Jimmy: YOU WANT HEAT?
WELL IT DOESN'T GET MUCH HOTTER
THAN WEARING TWO FACE MASKS AT
THE SAME TIME.
BECAUSE SLIDING INTO THE DMs
WILL MAKE THOSE GLASSES FOG
RIGHT UP
♪ MAKE THEM FOG ON UP
DON'T FORGET TO PU
SOME CHAPSTICK ON BEFORE
YOU DOUBLE THAT MASK ♪
♪ BEFORE YO
DOUBLE THAT MASK ♪
>> Jimmy: SO THIS FEBRUARY, LET
THE WORLD KNOW YOU TAKE
PROTECTION SERIOUSLY
AND SLIDE INTO THOSE DMs, THE
DOUBLE MASKS
♪ OH GIRL COME ON AND
DOUBLE THE MASKS
DOUBLE THAT MASK ♪
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE
>> Jimmy: HEY, LISTEN TO THIS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I READ THAT FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE HAS BEEN
SPOTTED ON VACATION IN THE
VIRGIN ISLANDS
I MEAN, OF COURSE HE VACATIONS
IN THE VIRGIN ISLANDS.
IT'S LIKE THE HEAD ALIEN
RETURNING TO THE MOTHERSHIP,
YOU KNOW
AS WE SPEAK, PENCE IS ENJOYING
A GLASS OF SKIM MILK WITH
A LITTLE UMBRELLA IN IT.
HONESTLY, I'M A LITTLE WORRIED
PENCE MIGHT HAVE SPENT TOO MUCH
TIME IN THE SUN.
DO WE HAVE A PHOTO OF HIM?
AH, A LITTLE CRISPY THERE.
SOME BUSINESS NEWS, YESTERDAY
GENERAL MOTORS MADE A PRETTY
IMPORTANT ANNOUNCEMENT
WATCH THIS
>> GENERAL MOTORS PLANS TO GO
ALL ELECTRIC BY THE YEAR 2035.
THE AUTO MAKER ANNOUNCING ITS
GOAL YESTERDAY TO END
PRODUCTION OF ALL DIESEL AND
GASOLINE POWERED CARS WITHIN
THE NEXT 14 YEARS.
>> Jimmy: YEAH
[ APPLAUSE ]
I'M NOT SURPRISED GM MADE THE
MOVE ESPECIALLY AFTER THEIR
LATEST GAS GUZZLER, THE
ESCALADE PYRAMID
[ LAUGHTER ]
YEAH, THERE ARE TWO THINGS
WE'RE HOPING WILL HAVE ZERO
EMISSIONS IN THE FUTURE, CARS
AND RUDY GIULIANI.
[ LIGHT LAUGHTER ]
NOW GET THIS, I READ THAT
POLICE IN PARIS ARE BEING
INVESTIGATED FOR BREAKING COVID
RULES BY HAVING A PARTY AT
THEIR STATION AND DANCING THE
MACARENA UNTIL 3:00 A.M.
YEAH, THE MACARENA
I HAVE SOMETHING I'D LIKE TO
SAY TO THEM, BUT SINCE THEY'RE
SO INTO '90s MUSIC, LET ME PUT
IT INTO TERMS THAT THEY'LL
UNDERSTAND
COME ON, YOU OUTTA KNOW BETTER,
DANCING UNTIL 3:00 A.M.,
UNBELIEVABLE
AND THE MACARENA
I MEAN, HOW BIZZARE.
I WISH YOU'D BE AN EXAMPLE AND
SAY "THIS IS HOW WE DO IT.
LISTEN, I GET IT
EVERY MORNING ALL I WANNA DO IS
RUN AROUND OUTSIDE
BELIEVE ME, BUT IF YOU SABOTAGE
THIS WHOLE THING, I'LL BE
REALLY UPSET AND I DON'T
WANNABE.
IN THE MEANTIME, QUIT LIVING LA
VIDA LOCA AND SAY "YOU CAN'T
TOUCH THIS" SO WE CAN ALL TELL
COVID "GOOD RIDDANCE."
THANK YOU.
[ APPLAUSE ]
EVERYTHING OKAY OVER THERE
ARE YOU FIXING A TOASTER OR
SOMETHING?
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND FINALLY, A METEOROLOGIST IN
CALIFORNIA WAS GIVING THE
WEATHER REPORT FROM HOME
YESTERDAY WHEN SHE HAD AN
ADORABLE VISITOR
TAKE A LOOK.
>> SO WE'RE WAITING FOR THAT
STORM TO ARRIVE HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND IT
LOOKS LIKE THERE'S A BABY DOWN
BELOW.
ALL RIGHT.
SANTA CLARITA 57, 66 DEGREES IN
CHINO, SANTA MONICA 61, 55 IN
VENTURA, AND IRVINE 64 DEGREES
AND 62 IN PASADENA
>> Jimmy: SHE WAS LIKE, COMING
UP AT 7:00, I ASK MY HUSBAND
WHY HE CAN'T DO ONE SIMPLE JOB
FOR FIVE MINUTES
[ LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE